[Music]
so I know that you have a very special
plus-one
but is here with you tonight so I like
to introduce her to eat see um this is
Mara Mara I is the executive director of
M Khan which is an amazing British black
feminist organization that tackles
violence against women and girls
specifically at the only women I have
learned so much from working with and
through my friendship with Mariah and
yeah we're just really excited to be
here tonight because it's this is just
unprecedented this show of solidarity
and unity with women across industries
across communities across different
ethnicities across different spaces it
is actually a really amazing opportunity
to just use this platform to highlight
all the different issues and to say you
know times up on violence against women
we're calling time like enough y'know
this is an inflection point we're not
going back I think that there's just
been this incredible breakthrough on
this and women are talking to one
another and we're forming communities
and we feel so strong together
I think that yeah and all I should
explain to there are activists that are
on the red carpet there's how many
totals seven I think that seven total
yes how did you get a call about hey we
wanted to take a plus-one or was how did
it come about that we would have you
incredible women who fight for other
women on the red carpet tonight I think
that it was I think it was Michelle
Williams actually the spearheaded this
idea and when I heard that she had had
this idea
and I just immediately thought of Mara
and I was like whoa if I could do the
red carpet with Mara then it would be
amazing way more fun than it normally is
and also she really knows what she's
talking about she's been doing this work
for over two decades and to hear her
voice in this space on this night that's
got to make you feel good hearing her
say that
I mean she's fierce and we have a really
good kind of vibe going on we work
together we have a lot of fun but we
also have a little challenge and a lot
of exchange of ideas and so for Emma to
invite me you know I don't take it
lightly I know it's a big deal but you
know it's also the opportunity to have
more voices amplified you know we've got
women of color in this space women of
color on represented in this industry
and we've got women of color in the
space as activists just kind of shaking
things up and so we step here with or
white sisters and we step in a space of
solidarity and that's amazing something
else I got to point out with her
standing next to me that the top three
movies at the box office all had female
leads and one of them was you Beauty and
the Beast yes this is very true we were
just saying about women power it's
there's a lot about women power and it
says that it's just crazy that this is a
novelty you know I mean less than 7%
I think of directors are women and less
than one
sent of minority women are directors
that is a crazy bigger only one woman
has ever won an Oscar for directing and
we need to see more female storytellers
in the space we need to see more diverse
storytellers in the space and you know
and amazing things can happen and they
will you know they will and can be at
the top three movies of the year and so
yeah exciting times very very exciting
you